it's not just on covet it's on the
ballots too it's on the vote as well
we're told there's no worries about the
vote oh yeah
yeah we've had uh mail-in voting now for
uh i don't know like a month
and we're we're moving voting way past
election day we're gonna have like weeks
and weeks of elections but don't worry
nothing could go wrong that things are
going wrong
things are going wrong in kentucky
postal worker in kentucky
was just arrested actually for election
interference we will get to
that in a second by the way thursday we
are going to be with you for the
presidential debate at backstage
check us out 8 45 pm eastern
5 45 pm pacific there will be an all new
episode
of backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major political event i'm sure it will
be very
controversial and crazy trust the
experts they told us
trust the system trust the process well
we can't can we because the experts got
covid completely wrong from the
beginning don't forget they told us
they told us we had to lock down they
told us we shouldn't have locked down
they told us don't wear the masks they
told us wear the masks all the time then
they didn't wear the masks themselves
then we were told
that any time anybody contradicts that
scientific success consensus they're
going to be kicked off of the internet
so
so much for open inquiry and debate same
thing with the voting
same thing with the voting we're seeing
that now in kentucky a u.s postal
service worker
threw away over 100 absentee ballots
meant for the jeffersontown area of
jefferson county
kentucky federal agents from the postal
service office of inspector general
found
the ballots on thursday morning after
they received a tip
100 ballots we've seen ballots on the
side of the road in new york we've
caught
election irregularities in new jersey
we've seen
some curious things in texas even
lots of issues here the experts are
going to tell you
that there has never been any problem
with mail-in voting
if you even suggest that there is going
to be fraud in this election
the social media will probably take your
post down
they'll say it's there's no evidence
that there has ever been fraud
there's no evidence well first of all
there is evidence in other
types of fraud but there's no evidence
that there's fraud in widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots because
we've never had them before
ever in the history of the country we
have never we've had absentee ballots
where you where an individual requests
the ballot and it comes to them
so there's a far less likely chance
that you're going to get ballots to
people who have been dead or to old pets
or to people who have moved people move
all the time
don't change their registration but in
this case because we know that the voter
registrations are out of date
you're just getting ballots they're just
being mailed out
we know that there have been ballot
harvesting schemes coast to coast
we know that there have been
irregularities we know that ballots have
gone missing
how many of these incidents like we're
seeing in kentucky have to happen
in pennsylvania or ohio or florida to
throw an election
how many people are going to vote twice
maybe not even intentionally just
they get a ballot they show up at the
polls how many people are going to vote
given a ballot that was for another
relative the other day i was walking
past a mailbox
ballot was just lying there right it was
like a kind of in an apartment building
and there was there were ballots on the
on the bench
anybody could take those ballots
we know that there's harvesting going on
at nursing homes
think about how razor thin the margins
have been on certain elections
and now you've got this obvious
vulnerability introduced into the system
what this would suggest to me is no
matter what happens
i think we're this thing is going to be
litigated up
you know maybe maybe all the way up to
the supreme court but certainly going to
be litigated
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you